the story of our world is a story that
is still very imperfectly known a couple
of hundred years ago men possessed the
history of little more than the last
three thousand years what had happened
before that time was a matter of legend
and speculation over a large part of the
civilized world it was believed and
taught that the world had been created
certainly in 4004 BC though authorities
differed as to whether this had occurred
in the spring or the autumn of that year
this fantastically precise misconception
was based upon a too literal
interpretation of the Hebrew Bible and
upon rather arbitrary theological
assumptions connected there with such
ideas have long since been abandoned by
religious teachers and this is
universally recognized that the universe
in which we live
has to all appearances existed for an
enormous period of time and possibly for
endless time of course there may be
deception in these appearances as a room
may be made to seem endless
by putting mirrors facing each other at
either end
[Music]
but that the universe in which we live
has existed only for six or seven
thousand years may be regarded as an
altogether exploded idea the earth as
everybody knows nowadays is a spheroid a
sphere slightly compressed orange
fashioned with a diameter of nearly
8,000 miles its spherical shape has been
known at least to a limited number of
intelligent people for nearly 2,500
years but before that time it was
supposed to be flat and various ideas
which now seem fantastic were
entertained about its relations to the
sky and the stars and the planets
we now know that it rotates upon its
axis every 24 hours which is about 24
miles shorter than its equatorial
diameter and that this is the cause of
the alternation of day and night that it
circles about the Sun in a slightly
distorted and slowly variable oval path
in a year its distance from the Sun
varies between 91 and half millions at
its nearest and ninety four and a half
million miles about the earth circles a
smaller sphere the moon at an average
distance of 239,000 miles Earth and Moon
are not the only bodies to travel around
the Sun there are also the planets
Mercury and Venus a distances of 36 and
37 millions of miles and beyond the
circle of the earth and disregarding a
belt of numerous smaller bodies the
planetoids
there are Mars Jupiter Saturn Uranus and
Neptune at meanne distances of a hundred
and forty-one 483 886 1782 and 1793
millions of miles respectively
[Music]
these figures in millions of miles are
very difficult for the minds to grasp it
may help the readers imagination if we
reduce the Sun and planets to a more
conceivable smaller scale if we then
represent our earth as a little ball of
one-inch diameter the Sun would be a big
globe nine feet across and 323 yards
away that is about a fifth of a mile
four or five minutes walking the moon
would be a small pea two feet and a half
from the world between Earth and Sun
there would be the two inner planets
Mercury and Venus at distances of 125
and 250 yards from the Sun all round and
about these bodies there would be
emptiness until you came to Mars a
hundred and seventy-five feet beyond the
earth Jupiter nearly a mile away a foot
in diameter Saturn a little smaller two
miles off Uranus four miles off and
Neptune six miles off then nothingness
and nothingness except for small
particles drifting scraps of attenuated
vapour thousands of miles the nearest
star to earth on this scale would be 40
thousand miles away
[Music]
these figures will perhaps serve to give
one some conception of the inmense
emptiness of space
in which the drama of life goes on for
in all of this enormous vacancy of space
we know certainly of life only upon the
surface of the earth it does not
penetrate much more than three miles
down into the four thousand miles that
separate us from the center of our globe
and it does not reach much more than
five miles above its surface apparently
all the limitlessness of space is
otherwise empty and dead the deepest
ocean dredging 'he's go down to five
miles the highest recorded flight of an
aeroplane is little more than four miles
men have reached to seven miles up in
balloons but at a great cost of
suffering no bird can fly so high as
five miles and small birds and insects
which have been carried up on airplanes
drop off insensible far below that level
[Music]
you